Just before you started with this one,
I do want to say that there's going to be some French pronunciations,
not a French speaker.
I am doing my best though.
George Washington Simon Boulevard even punch through via the names of the Great
North and South American revolutionaries.
Remain globally famous centuries on this one.
Great new wells,
redell many of forgotten he was a nobody.
He became a somebody only after 50 years of obscurity,
a freed slave who wound up leading the only successful large scale slave revolt
in history.
The general who made Haiti the second free colony in the whole of the Americas.
His name was too,
so the river tour,
Aka the Black Napoleon born into slavery over to his early life,
was an inspiring tale of overcoming a racist system to live a free man,
but it was his later years that were truly remarkable as he kept on rising until
he became ruler of the society that had enslaved them and enlightened thinker,
a prescient philosopher and a brilliant general that over to you.
I was also a man who dared to dream of freedom even if he wouldn't live.
To see those dreams fulfilled,
this is the story of the greatest black revolutionary who ever lived
imagined.
History is a vast cave,
swelling with shadows,
and each person's life is a distant torch.
Some of those lives like Napoleon's,
a gigantic pyres burning so brightly that you can't possibly miss them,
but others,
most of them a little more than matchsticks,
almost invisible.
It's into this category,
the early life of two song that ever true or false,
remarkably for a man who would go on to liberate an entire nation,
we know almost nothing about him.
We can say for certain that he was born in the French colony of Sandman,
now known as Haiti and 1741 just slave parents.
We can also say that his original name was to som Breda off to his plantation,
but beyond that,
everything is a myth and shadow the life of a slave and sandy was not pretty.
Ninety percent of the population lived in shackles while a few tens of thousands
of whites and fried collards,
as they were known existed in a state of luxury.
The average slave life expectancy was only 21 years.
Those who downs tools fought back or ran away,
could expect to be blinded or mutilators yes to Seoul was lucky.
One of the consistent themes of the conflicting accounts of his early years is
that he was born onto the plantation of a relatively enlightened master.
The wound you saw taught him French,
allowed him to gain some medical knowledge and promoted him to a job as a horse
trainer in 1776.
He even granted to song is freedom.
It's at this point to solemn briefly resends to the historical.
He married and had two kids and it's remarkably.
He even though disliked the own after this 15 more years passed in which to saw
left,
not even the slightest footprint on history by the time 1791 rolled around,
he was 50 and age at which most normal biographies are starting to wind down by
50.
Napoleon had already conquered half of Europe,
been defeated at Waterloo,
and then send him to exile by comparison to Sony was a small time farmer,
may ember in that dark cave of history that's on a diesel,
had every reason to believe he was going to die and nothing but obscurity.
Thankfully for our story though,
winds of change were starting to blow in Europe in no time at all to song and
everyone in Santa Monica would be consumed by the oncoming hurricane.
In 1799,
a group of friends,
radicals unknowingly lit the fuse on a gigantic pile of dynamite marked the
French revolution.
The ensuing explosion would shake up human history.
In most cases,
the effects will be felt until a few years down the line,
but Sandman wasn't most cases.
It was a radical tinderbox barely kept in check by far away Paris almost as soon
as the French Revolution spock's the entire country went up in flames.
By mid 17,
91,
everyone was aware of the storming of the Bastille and the declaration of the
rights of man.
This was a problem because the declaration was pretty clear that the rights of
men,
what universal,
which in Santa Mom,
they pretty clearly we're not the wide stumped on the colors.
He dumped on the freed blacks.
He dumped on the slaves with the whole system,
designed as a pyramids of exploitation.
If everyone was suddenly equal,
sound among would cease to exist for whites.
The French revolution represented both a threat and the chance to speak less
often declare a white supremacist republic for the college.
It represented a chance to finally knock the winds down,
a peg or two that year.
The two sides were almost openly potting revolts.
In doing so,
they failed to realize that a much larger group had seen in the revolution and
even bigger chance than they did out on the plantations and in the darkness of
the forests,
black slaves had began whispering to one another by the summer.
The whispers that turned into an idea,
which in turn became a plan.
Finally,
on the night of August,
the 14th,
17,
91,
a group of slaves met outside the capital of lcap performed a secret voodoo
ceremony that are under the stars.
They swore by blood to do the unthinkable.
They agreed to results if the French revolution started small before snowballing
into an unstoppable avalanche,
the Haitian Revolution went straight to the annihilating wall of ice and theory.
On August the 25th thousands of white plantation owners were woken by gangs of
slaves dragging them from their beds,
stabbing them,
shooting them,
beating them to death.
French children were dismembered.
Their heads displayed on poles outside of their former homes.
Fires were started.
Entire plantations bend to the grounds,
the horizon,
the turns and apocalyptic read.
The bloodshed was nearly worse.
The freed slaves in the countryside and the house slaves in the towns that
intended to coordinate the uprising,
but the field slaves jumped the gun and the whites and colors were able to
rounds up and massacre the town's slaves,
but it only put off the inevitable.
By late September,
over 100,000 slaves were in revolt and the cap was flooded with refugees.
Carrying horror stories of rape and mutilation,
the Haitian revolution it had begun,
so where was to solve in all of this while he was lying low,
refusing to either join the uprising or to condemn it,
something he was simply waiting to see if the revolt was going to burn out.
Others think he was giving his distance in case of white reprisals.
Whatever the reason is,
September into October,
and the fires grew until the countryside looked like a vision of hell.
Fifty year olds to song finally made his choice.
First,
he shipped his wife and children off to Santa Domingo,
the Spanish colony occupying the other half of the islands today known as the
Dominican Republic.
Then he quietly smuggled his old wide master and his family onto a boat headed
for the USA at lost with no one left to care for.
He freed,
slave,
abandoned his farm and disappeared into the forest.
It was the start of what would become a remarkable career,
but not straight away because of his medical knowledge to songs.
First posting was less black and Napoleon and more male.
Florence Nightingale,
a doctor for Georgia Bay ourselves.
Slave Amit,
he kept out of the thick of the fighting as 70 91 raged on and the bodies began
to pile high by the year's end,
some 4,000 whites and 15,000 blacks with debt.
The economy was in ruins.
The plantations were husks,
and a third of Omar was in the hands of the rebellious slaves by the time 1792.
Dawn's though to song was finally beginning to show his promised given 600
minutes of commands,
he quickly proved such an effective fighter that is ranks ballooned to 4,000,
although we're still answering to buy or sell now effectively had his own army
among their number was Jacques,
Jack Dslr,
a runaway slave who would become two songs and right on men.
While two songs on the gained fame for showing clemency to any whites they
captured.
That's the law when in the exact opposite direction,
a sadist with an overwhelming hatred of whites.
This alone which inflict old plantation punishments on his captives,
gouging out eyes,
and mutilating any French that he encountered before displaying their body parts
on Pike's.
Yes,
it'd be wrong to call Dessa law,
merely a psychopath.
Everything he did to his white captives had seen done by whites to slaves
countless times before.
White blonde had buried slaves alive,
bore them to death,
made them eat their own excrement.
It said that the sleep of reason produces monsters.
Well,
that's a long,
was the perfect monster for a system that has long ago lost all sense of reason
with decimals.
How do song was able to capture a huge swath of the countries north as 17.
Ninety three began their partnership at turned to songs,
fighters since perhaps the most effective slave army in Santa Monica.
It was at this time that he changed his name to look over it too,
which can be read as opening the way a possible reference to his military
victories,
but the war on Santa more had reached a kind of stalemate.
Whites were holed up in their cities.
The colors were attempting to establish a separate state in the south.
The other slave army commanders were just as powerful as to song what the
commands are needed was an outside force that would come and give the entire war
a gigantic shove.
Luckily that was bound to happen.
Seventy,
93 is the year both Spain and Britain decided to invade sound them all.
It was the chaos in metropolitan mainland France that allowed the two
superpowers to act with impunity.
Seventeen 93 was the year of the reign of terror in the anarchy.
The revolution has unleashed.
No one had any time to care about what was happening in the colonies.
Sound them all has long been prized by other Caribbean powers in both London and
Madrid.
I wanted to take it,
but while the British just straight up invaded,
the Spaniards arrived with a plan.
They're calling this in.
Santa Domingo opens communication channels with the slave army leaders promising
to respect their freedom.
If they fought for the Spanish crown,
it was a political master stroke.
Most of the slave leaders signed up to fight for Madrid's,
including the if a tour.
They were tired of France and so nothing new under a British regime accepts the
change of language.
However,
there were good reasons for thinking Luva too.
It wasn't exactly down with this pledge of allegiance to Spain that sorta bounce
of c come some of the remaining French troops in Santa Mall.
We're in a desperate position,
but that fortunes,
they were about to change.
The chaos in Paris had briefly calmed down enough for the new revolutionary
government to send out a delegation led by the portly abolitionist,
leggings for the seat sown,
Phonak's arriving in hazy sulfonex quickly divine's that there was only one way
to save the colony from implosion and conquest,
and it just so happened to align perfectly with his own beliefs on always the 29
slash 17 slash 93.
He did the unthinkable.
He unilaterally freed all the slaves.
At first I didn't believe him,
but 17,
94 lumberton interview.
It became clear that not only did softball next mean to keep the slaves free,
the governments in Paris actually backed him.
It was at this point the Louver tour and made the decision that would catapult
him to greatness over to us.
Army had taken control of the mountains,
giving them a natural,
easily defended base,
so over to your new that he was in a position of strength when he announced that
he was defecting from the Spanish.
From now on,
he would be fighting for the French.
The decision changed course of the war.
Labor deals army marched down from the mountains and decimated the Spanish
forces and their black allies.
Generals who nominally been over to her superiors only days before found
themselves forced into retreat into Santa Domingo as an overseer.
Cabs driving forwards.
The Spanish eventually capitulated having just lost her separate water.
France in Europe.
They agreed to give up Santa Domingo that vanquished black allies while they
were sent into exile,
but Louver tour.
He wasn't done yet,
but fitting his army around.
He now launched his full force against the coastal cities occupied by the
British.
Although the British would cling onto their sound Amar enclaves for a few more
years,
the game,
it was up under new verticals,
onslaught.
They were beaten down until the general was able to make peace on his own terms,
the deal that Britain could restart trading with sound Amar on solar condition
that louverture refrained from fermenting,
slave rebellion in Jamaica,
sends it over to your new British trade would be Kasia rebuilding the wall,
shattered economy.
This was a win win.
You've got everything you wanted,
and the British got to back out with a shred of dignity,
still intact as the British slowly packed up and left over to her,
turned his attention to the difficult problem of peace for the remaining whites
and colors.
This would have been a time of paralyzing fear.
The slave armies were notorious for their massacres and life under a former
slave must have been terrifying.
Prospect.
They have not counted on the overdose greatness rather than reprisals.
Lived here pursued a policy of reconciliation.
He forgave war crimes committed by whites.
He invited the plantation owners back,
offering them the same plantations that owns before and the chance to make their
money back.
He instituted a policy of colorblindness.
Everyone would be equal and no white would persecute any black,
just as no black would take vengeance upon any white for the slaves.
He maintained their freedom.
They would have to return to the old plantations and work for two years,
but they would receive wages and corporal punishments would be banned after the
two years were up.
That'd be free to go wherever they pleased it's moments such as these,
the show.
Why do you sold over to your remains a fascinating figure.
There was a man who just spent five years fighting a brutal race war and now he
was extending the hand of friendship to the very people who tried to kill him
and all of interest to general.
The video was capable of being a statesman who's pragmatism,
good Bible Washington's,
but there was still a dark side to leave it to you and it went by the name of
Joel.
Jack.
This along in the carnage of the civil war.
The colored said,
succeeded in carving out a small state in the south under the command of Andre
Rigor in 1799,
low poverty or send us along down to terminate the outpost,
which decimal did with extreme prejudice.
The war of knives was brutal.
It doesn't all slaughtered anyone who could even conceivably be a supporter of
rigo leaving a trail of death in his wake.
While Lovato was busy consolidating power in the north by exiling something
accent of the French authorities.
That's the little town in the south into central wasteland.
That reconciliation with the colored became impossible.
Bloody is.
It was the war of knives did succeed and reunifying Santa Mall for the first
time since 17,
91.
The entire country was under the control of one man and that man was over to
her.
As the clock ticked over in the 19th century,
began louvered here was slowly rebuilding the economy,
reestablishing race relations between blacks and whites and making plans to
eliminate slavery in Santa Domingo.
In short,
this extraordinary man was at the peak of his career.
It would take the arrival on the world stage of a man even more extraordinary
than lower tier to stop him.
Unfortunately for the population of Santa Monica,
that man was already waiting in the wings,
just as the Black Napoleon was consolidating,
has control over Sandamala in Europe,
the Real Napoleon was doing the same thing with France.
Seventeen 99,
so on.
Napoleon Bonaparte go from being a general in the revolutionary army to first
console of France as it is with many great men.
One stage simply wasn't big enough for both of them.
One of them,
Napoleon's first acts was to declare the French colonies would be governed by
special rules,
meaning the declaration of the rights of men would not apply since over to your
own,
has not actually declared independence from France.
Instead of insisting that he was ruling on behalf of Paris,
this was something of a problem.
Everyone knew that a slave economy could not be ruled by a former slave.
Not that things went immediately south though Louver to you publicly praised
Napoleon,
recognizing him as the new leader of France,
and he swore his loyalty to him.
His actions seem to mollify Napoleon,
the first consult confirms that over too,
as the legitimate leader of the colony of Santa Monica,
but he also issued him with a warning.
Lova too,
was not under any circumstances to invade Santa Domingo.
So now can you guess what you're did next?
At the time,
Santa Domingo was a vassal state,
technically ruled by frogs,
but still in the hands of Spanish administrators.
It also continued to practice slavery,
something lovatare couldn't tolerate his on his doorstep.
In Eighteen,
oh one he marched in,
sees the country and declared slavery abolished back in France.
The mouth hits the ventilator incense to bind it over to his actions.
The government demanded something be done.
Napoleon himself,
he communicated.
He had a vague plans.
Who invade America has recognized that sound.
Amal slave armies could help make that dream a reality,
but his wounded ego eventually got the better of him at the end of 18.
Oh,
one.
The first console dispatched a military expedition under the control of Charles.
Look to retake sound mall.
Not long after he passed the Lore of May the 20th bringing slavery back to the
colonies.
It was the beginning of the ends of both do sauna over tour and French control
of Santa Maher on paper over to you should have been able to rally popular
support in the face of a French invasion.
Sadly,
in reality is new equal society was not very popular.
The economy was still a shambles and the returned whites resented the empowered
blacks.
The colored still remember decimals atrocities.
The blacks,
well,
they may have technically been free,
but they were still stuck on that plantations of the three major demographics
and we'll send them all,
not one felt comfortable with the inverters.
Phoenix state as look like made landfall.
First,
the whites flocked to his side and the colored and then many of the slaves.
Finally,
even George drank the salon turns on his old friends and through his lot in with
the French and this one,
it was the end for lower tier.
After a few months of token resistance over to your contact at the clerk and
promise today down his arms in exchange for a guarantee that the French would
not reimpose.
Slavery began like agreed on two songs,
suspended military operations,
retiring to his old farm.
He was surprised with an invitation to meet a French general at an out of the
way plantation.
It was clearly a trap,
but over to here was maybe just too tired by his sudden fall from power by that
point,
whatever the reason he accepted as he arrived at the meeting spot,
he was arrested under the orders of Napoleon himself and deported France to solo
over to your manual,
had freed the slaves are ruled sound all for one brief shining moments would
never see us home again.
Send to the Jura mountains in southern France.
Liberty.
I spent the next year being beaten,
neglected,
and left to rot.
He wrote a bits like the dreamed a lot,
but in the cold mountain,
air is health collapsed by this point,
a man in his sixties,
lover to as body soon failed him.
He succumbs to repeated infections before finally slipping away.
On April the seventh,
18,
oh,
three black is white counterpart woods.
In 20 years,
the Black Napoleon died alone,
unloved,
and an exile is achievements seemingly forgotten.
Before he went over to her,
did have time to write his thoughts down on Santa Monica Future.
He felt the genie was out of the bottle and soon another black like in would
come along to permanently free the slaves and expel the French.
He was more right than he knew.
As he lay dying.
That's along.
I had switched sides again.
The cleric responded by trying to commit genocide against the slave population.
Even using ship holds filled with fumes as primitive gas chambers.
This was a bad decision.
The dark force driving decile law was more than equal to the clerks.
Demons stands in a genocidal war.
They could only be one winner in 18.
Oh,
three decimal systematically exterminated.
All of the whites in more men,
women,
children,
soldiers,
civilians,
each were butchered by a caravan of death that offered no mercy.
Only polls,
Brits and Americans were spared the former because many of them had arrived with
the clerical.
You need to switch sides the latter to you purely because that's a long knew
that he needed British and American trade to rebuild the economy.
The Clark himself didn't live to see this final French defeat.
He died of yellow fever in November of 18.
Oh,
two.
Just after launching his campaign of genocide on January the first 18,
oh,
four dozen law renames the nation Pacey and declared independence from France.
The slaves had done the impossible that fought for their freedom and then one,
although Haiti would endure centuries of economic misery,
natural disasters,
and occupation by powers including the United States,
it would never again be ruled by France.
All of this happens because of one man to Solon.
Level two,
you may not have lived to see it,
but his nation could never have one.
It's freedom without him.
It's thanks to the Black Napoleon that Santa more didn't really become another
British or Spanish outpost,
and it's thanks to his insistence on ending slavery that Haitians remained free
from 1794 onwards.
It was a great commander,
a shrewd statesman,
and a man who tirelessly advocated for racial equality.
His dream of creating an equal sound,
Amal may have failed,
but it was a noble dream or the same for that reason,
if no other to soul life for cure the slave,
it became a leader deserves to be remembered.
So I really hope you found that video interest,
and if you did,
please do give us a like below and don't forget to subscribe for brand new
videos every Monday and every Thursday and hit that bell button because
subscribed doesn't work like it used to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get all videos in your notification feed,
you do need to hit that bell.
So do that,
and as always,
I'll see you in the next video.